when it was the last time you cried last
time I cried well oh holy [ __ ] yes I was
in college and I wasn't happy in college
and I wanted to drop out and nobody was
supporting me so I started crying and I
was really sad about it thank you thank
you thank you for that new lifetime I
cried I was in middle school my kicker
watching Of Mice and Men and there we
got apart when George was about your
suit Lennie I mean snot on me we're not
about why the last time I cried was over
another person's wedding video that I
don't know okay
who but you cried at like the emotional
the ammonia of like someone else's
wedding video yeah which I was like wow
that's impressive the last time I cried
I watched a video Oh God
so what's your video of a dog it was one
of those dogs or like you find them in
like a like an abandoned area the person
gets the dog and like shaves them cleans
them up oh go ahead didn't Erica dog
well it turns into a good dog they
literally make me tear up every single
time holy [ __ ]
this is so sour or broke my headphones
hey same weed from one my grades were
bad I wasn't getting laid my parents
were married me and red there and there
I fell apart it's all about school mmm
when I got my Moochie sin was stolen
I took my phone my shoes and both of my
slides that's why I started to cry
I was watching chef's table I'm nap
what's watching the episode with Massimo
Vittorio
oh shoot is this sell taxes I was
watching the shadows like really
beautiful shots of food and I really
love food there's me it's passion for
food is so beautiful this is crazy
TV show this makes me cry ever oh I just
love that show for watching wanna learn
wanna like walking down slo-mo down the
mountain she said by her grandmother it
was always really sad why got engaged
move out and we got engaged to ever
gonna I Creek they were looking for this
[ __ ] moment and my emotion was
overcooked me
ration my crap mmm something I was
watching Malcolm in the Middle and it
was a highly emotional part of the show
look like a little tea had died oh the
bus flew in the creek and it was a bunch
of little kid in there and this
particular kid here like problems
growing and this little guy saved every
little kid and the bus Simon birch Simon
Bruce not Malcolm about to say I think
men are completely capable of emotion
and anyone who says like no like it's
not me I'm not emotional then like
you're suppressing
like important things and you're
probably going to have some sort of like
boil over at some point or another
[Music]